toute attaque contre des centrales
nucléaires est une chose suicidaire ce
sont les mots d'antonio goûter res
depuis le japon ce matin le secrétaire
général des nations unies vous le voyez
est sur place à l'occasion du 67e
anniversaire des bombardements
d'hiroshima et nagasaki
mais c'est bien le risque d'une
explosion nucléaire en ukraine qui
l'inquiète la centrale de zaporizhya a
une nouvelle fois été visé par des
frappes dans la nuit écoutez à ce sujet
du livre craag est justement notre
correspondant dans le pays
les ukrainiens par le biais d'
energoatom l' agence qui gère le
nucléaire en ukraine il estime que ce
que les rues sont en train de faire
c'est d'essayer de couper cette centrale
qui fournit 20% des besoins en
électricité de l'ukraine c'est la plus
grande centrale nucléaire d'europe 2 du
réseau d'électricité en ukraine et pour
pouvoir couper une grande partie de
l'ukraine de son électricité ce qui
serait une stratégie hautement risqué
d'autant plus risqué quand on sait que
les russes ont positionné du matériel
militaire à l'intérieur de deux des
bâtiments des réacteurs est généralement
sur le site ils sont trés blend bien
implanté il aime beaucoup ce site parce
que ils sont très bien protégées des
frappes ukrainienne alors ce même
directeur de l' agence energoatom quand
je lui ai parlé il ya une dizaine de
jours il m'a dit aussi que lui estimé
que les forces ukrainienne comprenait
très bien les risques et ne voudrait pas
frappé le site du central même mais
aurait plutôt une stratégie d' essayer
d'entourer et d'assiéger le site pour
ensuite négocier avec les russes pour
les convaincre de partir alors je pense
que les théories avancées par les
ukrainiens et aussi le fait qu' il
semble être bien conscients des dangers
et les 10 à répétition qu'ils n'ont
aucune intention de frapper le site
montrerait plutôt que ce sont les russes
qui en ce moment on ploie une stratégie
assez risqué sur ce site nucléaire de
zaporijia